[Music]
[Music]
when it comes to the history of zelda
there's no shortage of ancient
civilizations forgotten kingdoms or
secretive groups that have either
disappeared migrated elsewhere or fell
into decay after their glory days the
only clues of their existence are found
in old stories and legends the impact
they had on the history of the land be
it good or bad or the architecture they
left behind from the powerful
interlopers who got banished to another
dimension the tribe of winds who left
the surface to build a new home on the
cloud tops ancient sentient robots who
succumbed to severe climate change to
the still unsolved mystery of the zonai
a tribe of so-called barbarians who once
dominated the land of hyrule in an age
long ago witnessing the remnants of
their culture as they stand empty and
forgotten evokes a similar sense of
mystery and excitement the first
explorers must have felt when they first
stumbled upon the pyramids of giza or
the lost civilization of the inca it
makes you wonder what this place and its
people were all about what did it look
like in its glory days and what caused
its ultimate downfall the land of ikana
is one such location an ancient kingdom
lost a time a history of conflict and
bloodshed secrecy spies and dark magic
practices and now it stands crumbling
and empty well if you don't count ghosts
undead corpses or the resurrected bones
of its former inhabitants that is what
sets ikana apart from other lost
civilizations is that here the past
lingers on or perhaps more accurately
the past has been resurrected undead
soldiers commence guard duty as if
unaware that they have passed on packs
of gibdo's and re-dead shuffle around
mindlessly mysterious spies continue to
creep around keeping tabs on the kingdom
as they once did in life and the late
king sits on his throne awaiting the one
who can rid his land of darkness the
region of ikana is cursed and as far as
curses go it's one of the most
unsettling and powerful ones at that but
why is this is it all just the result of
majora's presence and influence did he
curse the region with his wicked magic
reanimating the dead as a way to bring
chaos or did he simply stir up something
much older something that already
existed long before the skull kid ever
put on the mask and started causing
trouble in the land of termina today we
will attempt to find out and i'm happy
to welcome nintendo black crisis back
once again to take part together we'll
try and find out why ikana became the
land of the dead how the ancient
conflict between two factions may have
been more than just your average war and
how it ties into the wickedness of
majora so join us as we unravel the
mysteries of ikana
[Music]
the history of the akana region is a
long one dating back to ancient times
the majority of its history is the
complete mystery all we know is that it
once housed a militaristic kingdom the
kingdom of ikana ruled over by a monarch
and that at some point the kingdom
crumbled due to a long and bloody
conflict with a rival faction
the gero
ikana seems to have had a similar power
structure and medieval technology as the
kingdom of hyrule they are portrayed as
proud swordsmen with a strong and
disciplined army made up of guards foot
soldiers generals and so on they were
also skilled in the use of magic
particularly through music
this is reflected by their knowledge of
the son of storms and the elegy of
emptiness the garrow on the other hand
are more comparable to the shika
stealthy and ninja-like they deployed
many spies into the kingdom to keep tabs
on the royal family and high-ranking
officials
gathering information about their
strategies and advancements from the
shadows perhaps their most chilling
trait is that in the case of defeat they
are instructed by garrow law to commit
suicide to avoid capture in the entirety
of the game we only witness two
different ranks within the gyro
hierarchy the regular spies who stalk
the village and castle courtyard and
aguero master who presumably commands
them there's not a whole lot of
information about the war between the
two factions all we know is that it was
lawn filled with bloodshed and
ultimately contributed to the death and
downfall of their culture and societies
cut to the present day and ikana has
since turned to ruin an abandoned ghost
town hidden within the canyons the only
living souls that remain in the area
nowadays are a paranormal researcher and
his young daughter who study the ghostly
activity a lone grave keeper who
continues to tend to the nearby
graveyard and a thief by the name of
sakon who uses the lonely canyon as a
hideout
now in terms of layout there is only a
few notable landmarks within ikana as
it's relatively small the entrance to
the region is indicated by eight
decorative stone pillars beyond this
point there is a trail that forks into
two directions one leading into the
akana graveyard and the other into ikana
village inside the village we find the
former seat of power
the imposing ancient castle of ikana a
few abandoned houses the music box house
which is where the researcher and his
daughter are held up and a deep well
that runs underneath the village and
into the castle courtyard additionally
at the edge of town there's a secret
shrine hidden behind a waterfall and a
cave that serves as the hideout for the
thief sakon
lastly we have the by far biggest and
most mysterious landmark the stone tower
looming over the village and castle
embedded within the mountain stands an
enormous structure reaching high up into
the skies
so high in fact that it can be seen
towering in the distance from almost
anywhere on the map
inside this tower at the very peak lies
the stone tower temple one of the most
mysterious dungeons in the entire series
when it comes to its purpose and history
but we'll get to that later
many people seem to believe that ikana
has been abandoned ever since the fall
of the ancient kingdom but there are a
few things that contradict this notion
first is a quote from sakon who says
you know lately frightening ghosts have
been appearing in swarms in ikana
village across the river it seems
they're the ghosts of ikana's royal
family or something there's no one
living there anymore so i moved nearby
there's also a paragraph in hyrule
encyclopedia that states
to the east of clock town is a canyon
where the iconic kingdom once flourished
after the stone tower gate was opened
the region was overrun by the dead and
the people of ikana village fled
when link reaches the canyon the only
people who live there are a girl named
pamela and her father a paranormal
researcher
this seems to suggest that there were
actually people living normal lives
inside the canyon village up until
recent events when skull kid showed up
in termina and started causing problems
this explains why dampe is still tending
to the graveyard even though the canyon
is mostly devoid of life the graveyard
was clearly constructed by the ancient
kingdom and served as a burial ground
for the most decorated soldiers and
other people of importance it's also
where they kept some of their most
valued treasures and the graveyard was
of such importance that it remained
under constant guard perhaps the people
who lived in ikana in the present day
wanted to show their respects to this
ancient burial site and thus someone was
appointed to take care of it at all
times
dampe explains that his father took care
of the graveyard before he did and his
old man seems to have known quite a lot
about some of the ancient history of
ikana especially the history of the
graveyard itself after skull kid under
the influence of majora's mask started
messing with the province the dead
started to rise in mass and the village
and surrounding area became a place no
longer safe for the living thus most of
its inhabitants fled however dampe
despite his fears may have felt a sworn
duty to stay and tend to this historic
place like his father before him
but the big question that everyone has
when it comes to ikana is
why are the dead plaguing the area in
the first place
i mean ghosts and the undead are nothing
new to the series but this is by far one
of the most extreme places we've ever
seen the closest contender being the
underground catacombs of kakariko
village from ocarina of time and similar
to kakariko it likely has a strong
connection to its dark history as the
spirit of the poe collector states ikana
is stained with a history of darkness
drenched in blood but there has to be
more to it than that after all the dead
didn't start becoming active again until
recently in order to find out we first
have to take a closer look at the bloody
conflict between ikana and the gero
as stated before not a whole lot is
known about the war that once raged in
ikana we know that there was a lot of
bloodshed a lot of fighting spying
secrecy and so on but we have no idea
why the garrow and the kingdom were at
odds with each other it's clear that the
kingdom dominated the province as most
of the structures found here are by
their making but interestingly enough
their adversary the garrow are almost a
complete mystery there's only one line
in the game devoted to their origin
stating that they came from an enemy
nation and that they were sent to
investigate ikana but we never actually
see this supposed enemy nation the
garrow are set to originate from no
trace of a garrow homeworld or anything
like it now some speculate that the
gyara were held up inside stone tower
and there is one indication that this is
true as inside stone tower temple is
where we find the garo master the one
who was supposedly in command thing is
stone tower as far as we know only has
one way in and out through the front
entrance which is also known as the
stone tower gate while it could
definitely be that the garrow had seized
control of stone tower during the war
i'm very much doubtful that this was
their homeland nobody knows who
constructed stone tower or the temple
that lies within nor do we know its
purpose but it almost certainly wasn't
the garrow or the kingdom of ikana who
built it as mentioned before the garrow
are set to originate from an enemy
nation outside the borders of ikana and
perhaps even outside the borders of
termina as a whole seeing as stone tower
is part of the akana province it's
highly unlikely that they were the ones
who built it the kingdom of ikana does
have some very impressive stonework to
their name but the notion that they were
the ones who constructed it also has
some stuff working against it first off
the decorations and architecture inside
stone tower temple doesn't match at all
with that of ikana castle ikana and
stone tower both have a very distinct
style which isn't found in one or the
other the crest of ikana which many of
its high-ranking officials wear is also
nowhere to be found inside the tower
you'd think that if they constructed
such an impressive feat of engineering
and architecture they'd at least want to
let the world know that they were the
ones responsible for it they seem like
very prideful people second is the fact
that the late king himself tells link
that stone tower is an impenetrable
stronghold and that hundreds of his
soldiers wouldn't even be able to topple
it indicating that they did try to reach
the temple at some point but failed
whenever he mentions the tower or temple
there's nothing that indicates that they
were responsible for its construction in
fact he seems to fear it and speaks ill
of the place whoever did build a tower
is anyone's guess but it was likely long
before the kingdom of ikana was even
founded we'll do a little bit of
speculating at the very end but for now
the question of who isn't all that
important what is important is that
which is found inside stone tower or
more specifically inside the temple that
resides there something that if true
could be the key to finding out the
cause behind the war between nagaro and
ikana there's one thing that makes stone
tower temple stand out from all the
other dungeons in the game and no it's
not the fact that the entire dungeon can
be flipped upside down well not entirely
anyway it's what happens after the
dungeon is flipped that makes it
interesting in all prior dungeons when
link gains access to the boss chamber he
will fight the boss inside of a confined
room these rooms are also unmistakably
still within the dungeon itself he
either simply walks through a door or
drops down a hole into a chamber below
the architecture and environment of
these rooms are also consistent with the
rest of the structure except in stone
tower temple here link falls into some
sort of strange portal only to emerge
inside of a vast desert land that serves
as the battle arena to fight twinmold
this of course begs the question what is
this place
how did we get from a tower high up in
the sky upside down no less to a desert
in the middle of nowhere on ground level
at first i thought this place might be
something similar to the rooms the
giants reside in you know after beating
one of the dungeons but there's too many
obvious differences between the two the
giant rooms are surreal hazy almost all
white in fact it kind of reminds me of
the spared realm where the hero shade
lingers in twilight princess the twin
mole battle arena doesn't look like a
spirit realm at all it looks like any
other desert inside the normal world it
has a cloudy blue sky first of all
there's buildings and ruins off in the
distance and a vast horizon of sand
dunes stretching out quite far quite the
contrast to the white cloud barrier
surrounding the giant rooms so could it
be that the land we're looking at right
here is in fact the garrow homeworld
there's definitely buildings present
that look like they may have housed
people at some point and the
architecture of these seems to be new
and unique aesthetically the garo
themselves also look like they could
have originated from a desert-like
environment in fact they kind of remind
me of the jawas from star wars
even their weaponry has a lot in common
with that of the gerudo a popular theory
about stone tower and its adjacent
temple is that they were built for the
purpose of mocking or challenging the
gods this is based on the idea that
stone tower was derived from the tower
of babel a mythical tower from the
hebrew bible that was built in an
attempt to reach the heavens however god
did not take kindly to this effort and
prevented the tower from being finished
however this inspiration has never been
confirmed by any of the developers of
the game it is and still remains a fan
theory based on the similarities between
the two so what if the purpose of stone
tower wasn't to insult the gods but
rather an attempt to create a portal
between two dimensions i mean it looks
like a portal and the fact that we go
from a tower in the sky to a seemingly
disconnected desert world definitely
suggests that it acts like one too
whoever built stone tower far far in the
past may have done so to create a rift
between two worlds whether it's because
they wanted to find a way out of termina
or seek dominion over another dimension
i have no idea but after their
disappearance the portal they created
continued to exist in this location the
garrow nor the kingdom of ikana likely
had anything to do with the creation of
this portal but the unfortunate
byproduct of this rift could have been
that it brought the two nations on each
other's doorstep the garrow may have
discovered the portal inside their
homeland by accident used it to enter
termina and straight into the territory
of a war-like nation who clearly didn't
take too kindly to their visit and
likely viewed them as an invading force
one more clue that this is what could
have happened is the garrow master
inside the stone tower temple when link
enters the room where the fight takes
place the master appears from a hole in
the ceiling and this hole just so
happens to be the very same one the
portal is located in when the temple is
flipped upside down an interesting
coincidence for sure
[Music]
if the creation of a rift and the
subsequent conflict that arose from it
is true that means that the war between
ikana and guerrero wasn't your average
war between two bordering nations but in
fact an interdimensional one two worlds
that were brought together because of an
effort made a long time ago by a
mysterious unknown group of people
but what other world are we talking
about here we know the zelda series is
rife with other dimensions parallel
worlds and different realms in fact the
rooms mentioned earlier where the giants
reside are called giants realm in the
game's code it goes without saying that
we may never know for sure unless
nintendo themselves decide to chime in
it could be a completely new previously
unseen world altogether in that case the
gyro may have originated from a place
unknown which would explain why they are
unique to majora's mask alone and not
found in any other game one of only a
few zelda enemies to do so but what if
it isn't a new world what if it's a
world we've already been to before one
we are all too familiar with we are of
course talking about hyrule this may
sound like a shot in the dark but
there's actually some substance to this
idea the first and most obvious fact is
that there is already one portal that we
know of that connects hyrule and termina
the one that link the skull kid and
possibly the happy mask salesmen use to
enter termina it connects the lost woods
to a basement underneath the clock tower
inside clocktown not to mention that
both portals share a similar trait of
flipping things upside down if there's
anything we know about termina it's that
it's a world that lies parallel to
hyrule perhaps the only way to access
one world from the other is to literally
go upside down from where you started in
the lost woods portal this is achieved
by going deep deep underground
but perhaps the ancient people who built
the stone tower found a different way to
achieve the same goal instead of going
deep down they went high up into the
skies
at the time of the stone tower's
construction the portal inside clock
town may not have even existed yet heck
clock town itself probably didn't exist
at this time and even if the portal was
already there it could be that it wasn't
discovered yet considering it's hidden
underground but there's more that
indicates a possible connection to stone
tower and hyrule it's well known that
the triforce doesn't play a role in
majora's mask because it's a land with
its own deities and beliefs the
developers even went as far as to remove
any triforce imagery from assets and
models that were reused from ocarina of
time for the sake of consistency however
there are a few instances where the
triforce imagery still persists and all
of them are connected to ikana they can
be found on the ancient pillars leading
to ikana as well as on the blocks link
uses to bridge the gap towards the
entrance to the stone tower temple
what's even crazier is that these
triforce decorations are at the bottom
of the blocks and don't become
noticeable until the tower is upside
down unfortunately these triforce
depictions were removed for the 3ds
version but they didn't get rid of all
the triforce imagery here either as
there are some gold bars found in
sakon's hideout and the treasure chest
minigame that have the symbol of the
triforce on them strangely enough this
isn't because they reused the assets
from ocarina of time 3d and forgot to
remove the symbol there are gold bars
found in that game as well but these are
blank so this asset is actually unique
whether that means this gold originated
from hyrule and was brought to termina
at some point we will leave up to you to
decide however the same thing applies to
the ikana triforce imagery from the
original majora's mask in any other
instance such as the triforce symbol
showing up on the armor of the clocktown
guards or something like that we could
easily chalk it up as a simple oversight
majora reused a lot of assets from
ocarina so a mistake like that would be
completely understandable
thing is the blocks and pillars in ikana
are not reused assets
they are unique to majora and
specifically made for this game how is
it that they remembered to remove all
references to the triforce from
ocarina's textures only to design a
brand new texture featuring the triforce
by accident and not just any triforce
symbolism but one that is mixed into the
art style of ancient ikana and ikana
alone obviously for the sake of this
theory there is clear bias here but i
don't think it's outside the realm of
possibility that their removal of the
3ds version may have been a mistake we
have to remember that this remake was
done by grezzo a third-party developer
the textures of majora were not upscaled
but completely redone from the ground up
it could be that whoever remade the
textures for the akana assets removed
the triforce references in favor for
their own design without realizing that
they erased an essential clue that was
put there on purpose by the original
artists
the final clue that shows a possible
connection between hyrule and stone
tower is found in the ancient backstory
of the four giants and skull kid it
tells of their friendship and the
betrayal and neglect the imp felt when
the four deities left for the corners of
the earth in an act of rage and sadness
skull kids started causing problems for
the people of termina who used the song
and prayer to ask the giants to step in
when they did they threatened to tear
the skull kid apart which frightened the
imp so much that he departed the world
and returned to the heavens
now in hyrule encyclopedia it states
that it can be theorized that the giants
of the four worlds exist which they do
that the imp is skull kid which it is
and that the heavens are hyrule and
while this is just a book when it comes
to what we know about skull kid this
does seem to add up after all we
actually meet this particular skull kid
inside the lost woods during the events
of ocarina of time which is well before
the events in termina play out this
means that skull kid already went to
termina a very long time ago then ended
up in hyrule at some point only to
travel back to termina again after the
events of ocarina this could mean that
heavens in this context isn't referring
to the heavenly realm or the afterlife
but instead the connection between
termina and hyrule which was and still
is found inside stone tower close to the
heavens something similar is mentioned
after defeating the geromaster inside
stone tower as a parting gift he reveals
to link how he can flip the tower upside
down stating that if you shoot that
which releases the sacred golden light
into the blood-stained red emblem
outside the temple it shall rearrange
things in which the earth is born into
the heavens and the moon is born on the
earth the whole idea of a two separate
yet connected worlds is also hinted at
on some of the decorations inside the
stone tower temple itself a depiction of
two suns a red one and a yellow one now
notice how on the clocks used in termina
the sun is always depicted as red this
could mean that the red sun depicted
inside the temple represents the sun or
world of termina while the other
represents that of the otherworld in
regards to the gero one might ask the
question if the gero originated from
hyrule then why did we never see them in
ocarina of time or any other game taking
place in hyrule for that matter well we
have to remember that the borders we see
in maps like the ones from ocarina of
time don't always represent the borders
of the kingdom as a whole it only
displays the explorable space if
anything twilight princess demonstrated
that the desert is a whole lot bigger
than the area we were allowed to visit
in ocarina of time who knows how far the
desert stretches on beyond the desert
colossus it's fairly easy to believe
that somewhere deep inside the desert
other tribes have existed and maybe
still do uncontacted and undisturbed and
of course by the time they would have
found their way into termina all the
gyro were essentially wiped out in the
war erasing them from both worlds
altogether if this other world indeed
exists it is of course up for debate if
this is indeed hyrule it's the only
option that has actual evidence to
support it but it could just as well be
a completely different world altogether
nevertheless the idea that more than one
portal exists within the world also fits
perfectly with that which termina is
supposed to represent onuma himself has
confirmed that the name termina is
derived from the word terminal and no
not terminal as in terminally ill or
link dying but as in an airport terminal
for example a place where people come
and go a world between worlds whether
all portals lead to hyrule or if there's
access to other realms as well is
anyone's guess but it's at least in line
with that which this world is supposed
to be
so that takes care of the possible
purpose of stone tower and how it
ignited a conflict between two different
dimensions but it fails to explain one
thing
why did the dead rise within ikana
[Music]
the exact reason why the dead linger in
ikana is never outright explained by the
game itself one of the royal composers
sharp does mention that he dreamt of
reviving the royal family and that he
was tricked by the masked one but he
also makes it clear that this was a
personal curse after bringing him back
to his senses with the song of storms
nothing changes in ikana except that the
river starts flowing again the dead
still roam the land unchecked he also
mentions that the roots of the curse lie
within stone tower this is confirmed by
the king igos do akana who says that it
all happened after somebody thrust open
the doors of that stone tower that
somebody is speculated to have been
skull kid or rather majira's mask and i
do agree that this is the most likely
scenario i however do not believe that
majora is responsible for the curse
itself whatever caused the land of ikana
to become so cursed likely existed long
before skull kid ever set foot in the
region in fact the curse doesn't really
need to be attributed to one single
individual the war and bloodshed itself
would already suffice for something like
this to happen we've seen it happen
before remember the shadow temple or
rather kakariko village as a whole a
place where unspeakable cruelties hatred
and bloodshed took place for many years
during the hyrulean civil war even the
description of ikana and the shadow
temple have quite a lot in common here
lies hyrule's bloody history of greed
and hatred ikana kingdom stained with a
history of darkness drenched in blood it
also fits well with a lot of japanese
folklore the idea that extreme emotions
such as rage hatred and sadness can
linger rendering a location object or
even a person cursed or haunted the
curse is so powerful and deeply rooted
that even the song of healing doesn't do
the job playing the song before sharp
does yield a response he says that it
eases his heart but also says that to
one of the dead and darkness like
himself a song like that no longer holds
meaning so whatever is keeping the
spirits of ikana up and about is so
powerful that they are beyond healing so
then what's keeping them here from what
we can gather during or after the war
between akana and nagaro someone took
the initiative to seal the doors leading
to the stone tower possibly severing the
connection between the two nations this
action may have put the past to rest at
least for the time being and akana
became a safe place to live again as
long as that door remained closed the
dead would be at ease so when the king
mentions someone opening the doors to
stone tower that might be all there is
to it reopening the gates to stone tower
the origin point of the war may have
reignited the emotions of conflict and
thus the dead rose back up repeating and
reliving the past as if the war never
ended one indication of this is what
happens after beating twin mold and
clearing stone tower temple in any other
region clearing its temple causes the
land to return back to normal the
poisoned waters of the swamp become
clear again spring finally arrives in
the mountains and the ocean of great bay
is slowly returning back to normal as
well but in ikana nothing changes when
beating twinmold and freeing the giant
the dead continue to roam the land
regardless and to take it even further
not even majora's defeat brings peace to
the living dead as we can still see the
ghost of the king and his henchmen
during the credit sequence if the roots
of the curse indeed doesn't lie with
majora or twin mold then what the king
said about how it all started when the
door to stone tower was opened explains
everything after all the entrance to the
tower still remains open even after
clearing its dungeon unless someone
wises up and seals that door the dead
may continue to linger for all eternity
so in that sense majora didn't have to
do all that much really the foundation
for the curse was probably already there
all it needed was a little nudge of
course it could be that the curse that
rests on ikana cannot be attributed to
just one thing but an amalgamation of
many the presence of majora the years of
bloodshed messing around with dark magic
and wicked songs and the doors to stone
tower being breached either way i hope
that those trapped inside these ancient
battlegrounds will be able to find peace
someday
the idea that stone tower once acted as
a gateway between termina and possibly
hyrule opens up so many more
possibilities when it comes to zelda
lore take for example the ancient tribe
who created majora's mask and then
completely vanished later on some have
suggested that this mystery tribe is
somehow connected to the interlopers
later known as the twilight due to some
of the resemblance between the fused
shadow and majora's mask
well if it's true that stone tower was
built in ancient times that could mean
that this occurred during hyrule's
ancient past as well this opens up the
possibility that the ancient tribe of
majora made their way from termina into
hyrule and later became known as the
dark interlopers after all it never
specifically says that they were hylians
by descent all it says is that among
those living in the light a group
emerged who excelled at powerful magic
which fits perfectly with the tribe of
majora a powerful tribe who created a
weapon so fierce that even they
themselves came to fear it
this is all just speculation of course
and perhaps the rabbit hole doesn't go
that deep but it is fun to think about
regardless even with all that said we
still haven't even scratched the surface
yet when it comes to all there is to
know about ikana there's an entire web
of people who have a connection to ikana
in some way shape or form we have the
secret shrine which is filled with
unexpected majora imagery and we haven't
even touched on some of the magic that
was used like the sun of storms or the
elegy of emptiness two songs with strong
magic power attached to them in fact i
myself have wanted to cover this topic
for a while so chances are you'll see a
video all about ikana and its close
connections to the dead on my channel in
the coming weeks and of course monster
maze will be joining me on that topic so
if the video does get released there
will be a link in the description down
below or you can keep an eye on my
channel nintendo black crisis or follow
me on twitter at nintendo black c
and that concludes the video i hope i
was able to pitch some new ideas about a
game released almost 22 years ago please
give it up for nintendo black crisis for
once again enriching one of my videos
with his presence as well as saving me
from having to record a 10-page
voice-over all by myself a big thanks as
always goes to my mods on discord and my
live streams and to my gracious patreons
and channel members if you will give a
warm welcome to a brand new very
generous supporter on patreon jordan
koncha as well as a new channel member
danio reddy thank you both so much it
means a lot and that is all for now this
is dawn signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you